il semble qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
vidéos d'actes malveillants qui émerge
sur les réseaux sociaux est ce que cela
représente une réalité pour certains ça
ne fait pas de doute comme le président
de la république lui-même nous sommes
dans une société qui est plus en plus
violentes et sa re sortait beaucoup
aussi des débats je pense que cette
violence endémique je dirais elle est là
et il ya une dégradation très nette mais
pour eric dupond-moretti ministre de la
justice c'est un peu plus flou la
délinquance n'a pas augmenté la violence
oui en revanche j'ai toujours dit que la
violence n'avait pas augmenté j'ai
toujours dit chiffres à l'appui que la
justice n'était pas laxiste ce qui est
vrai c'est que la délinquance des
mineurs est marqué par davantage de
violence ça c'est une absolue certitude
alors vos factures on va essayer d'y
voir plus clair et d'évaluer si oui ou
non l'insécurité est croissante depuis
dix ans
[Musique]
en france il existe deux moyens de
connaître les chiffres de la violence
d'abord il ya les chiffres de la police
qui sont mises à jour chaque mois sur le
site du ministère de l'intérieur ce sont
toutes les plaintes enregistrées par la
police ou la gendarmerie et transmises à
la justice puis de l'autre côté il ya
les enquêtes de victimation mise en
place en france dans les années 1990 il
s'agit d'une enquête menée sur 16000
personnes et là cette analyse plus fine
plus en profondeur qui permet de faire
remonter la zone grise des faits ce qui
ne se les événements pour lesquels les
françaises ne vont pas forcément porté
plainte mais qu'ils ont subi
mais ces sondages souffre d'un manque de
transparence en 2020 il n'y a pas eu
d'un pet en 2021 l'insee n'a fait une
enquête que sur un échantillon très
réduit dans la tête en bas valeur
nettement moins et puis bin c'est
abandonner cette tempête est elle allée
cellonis terme intérieur l'arpentent de
qui fait craindre une rupture des séries
je veux dire par ce terme une difficulté
à se rendre compte de l'évolution pour
jean-marc leclerc cette opacité n'est
pas anodine en fait on a quand même le
sérieux sentiment que al'approche
d'élection présidentielle
le pouvoir est tenté de casser le
thermomètre mais penchons nous sur ces
données si on regarde à la fois les
enquêtes de victimation et les chiffres
du ministère de l'intérieur ils
indiquent tous deux une baisse certaine
des violences crapuleuses c'est-à-dire
celles qui ont pour but le vol ou la
dépouille disons que heureux
un quart de siècle les homicides
attentat terroriste est naturellement
sont au plus bas les agressions
physiques
mais disons pour être simple caleçon
toujours dans le même ordre de grandeur
quant au volet oliver et bien
ils sont globalement
en forte baisse depuis des années mais
ici ce sont surtout aujourd'hui les
violences
non crapuleuses qui augmentent et qui
sont leur a vraiment le révélateur d'une
tension en quelque sorte social puisque
ça n'est pas le désir de voler qui
motive le coup c'est l'irascibilité
c'est la vengeance c'est voilà c'est ce
genre de choses donc c'est du rapport
humain en effet qu importe la provenance
des zones et elle montre bien une
évolution à la hausse des violences non
crapuleuses
si les homicides reste assez stable
depuis 2008 et coups et blessures le
grain en flèche selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur et ce partout
en france les secteurs ruraux
périurbains
de la gendarmerie nationale et bien
commence à vivre les mêmes choses et
commence à vis des femmes des phénomènes
de délinquance de masse importante et
c'est tellement vrai que à titre
d'exemple dans les six premiers mois de
l'année on se rend compte que des
secteurs où les où la violence augmente
le plus ces décès des départements dans
des départements ruraux de la
gendarmerie où on a des hausses entre 40
et 60% en ille et vilaine dans le
calvados dans le lot et garonne en saône
et loire etc il faut cependant noter que
l'année 2020 a vu tous les compteurs
chuté la raison est simple il est
évident que pendant les mois de
confinement où les gens étaient privés
de sortie ont comptabilisé moins de
violences de rues seul endroit qui a
connu une croissance le foyer la crise
sanitaire elle a eu un effet indéniable
sur les violences intrafamiliales
les gens ont vécu les uns sur les autres
il ya eu de la tension on parlait
l'irascibilité c'est ça
donc ça a indéniablement ça a explosé et
ça mettra du temps à retomber mais cette
hausse peut aussi s'expliquer par
l'appel à l'intransigeance notamment en
matière de violences sexuelles et
intrafamiliales si les gens sont appelés
à ne rien laisser passer très tellement
des chiffres augmentent prenons par
exemple les violences sexistes la
croissance des violences enregistrées
par la police et la gendarmerie est très
nette de même que celle ressentie dans
l' enquête de victimation cette
explosion correspond notamment avec
l'apparition du mouvement me to qui
engendrait une modification des
perceptions pour autant la flambée de
ces chiffres ne veut pas forcément dire
que ces violences n'existait pas avant
quand les jours révèle des faits qui
l'ont vécu qu'ils ont subi ils font
remonter une réalité le fait d'aller
inciter les victimes à porter plainte ça
nourrit pas un sentiment ou ça ça permet
de connaître la réalité des phénomènes
criminels pour les agressions sexuelles
mais aussi pour des violences
intrafamiliales
il y a eu un phénomène qu'on pourrait
appeler de des camouflages ces dernières
années ou de passage si vous voulez du
congo ce qui fait que nous ne savons pas
trop qui se sur enregistrement policiers
traduit une augmentation
dont c'est fait ou unité g probant
propension des victimes pas s'en
plaindre aux autres une question se pose
donc celle du ressenti si une grande
partie des violences reste stable les
français eux se sentent plus en sécurité
ces derniers mois à 71% selon un sondage
réalisé par l'ifop pour sud radio et ses
news et cela même s'ils ne sont pas
directement menacées faisons un
parallèle vous pouvez vous sentir
menacés par le risque de chômage
personnellement
mais vous pouvez aussi ne pas vous
sentir menacés mais considéré que le
chômage s'est ain bourg grave
et ce sentiment peut s'expliquer par une
cause des violences non plus en quantité
les en intensité on voit bien que les
professionnels de la sécurité en dur des
choses beaucoup plus dures contre x que
la violence est beaucoup plus présente
dans les rapports qu'ils ont avec la
population que voilà il ya une tension
perceptible elle est perceptible dans
les chiffres mais les perceptives aussi
dans les témoignages des acteurs de la
sécurité avec la hausse de certaines
violences notamment les violences
sexuelles et les actes malveillants 10
gratuit
les politiques vont devoir réfléchir à
des solutions pour répondre à l'une des
cinq préoccupation majeure des français
depuis de nombreuses années